let's go into what actually is a code
review so some formal definition here
but basically when a developer writes
new code or port owner could be I don't
know and they want to get it into the
code base they ask another developer to
review their code and the reviewer can
look and find certain issues or or find
certain improvements that can be made
and when that's approved it can go into
the main code base that's kind of the
gist of what a code review is right so
why would you do a code review so um who
can tell me how do you know your code is
readable
okay okay okay yeah so you define a
structure for everyone to follow and
okay and anyway anyone else that's the
one exactly when someone else can read
your code that's how you know it's real
and the the the structure is very
important because that's what you fall
back into it that's what everyone
understands and that should help you
achieve the goal of having someone else
be able to read your code because I can
follow P as r2 and still make code you
wouldn't understand I don't do that
every day generally so readability right
architecture is also very important when
you have this well let's say it's pool
request in front of you these these
changes you can really think about you
know what we just build does it does it
really fit into our our architecture I'm
not saying you should always look at
that after you build a feature but it's
still a good way of checking like okay
so we made a decision on how we're going
to build this but let's evaluate this
this is actually working out and you can
reevaluate this during a court review
and then we have share of knowledge also
a very interesting because to me one of
the best ways of onboarding someone is
actually having that person do
use reason for that is when you do a
code review you can see this feature is
being introduced and this part changes
this part changes and this part change
of the system and that's very useful
information so that person now knows
that if that person has to introduce a
certain feature it knows what he or she
knows where to look at the moving parts
of the application basically so that's a
very interesting way of onboarding
someone next to that I don't really like
documentation myself so I much rather do
code reviews to keep it going and just
keep my knowledge up and then of course
we have books is a very straightforward
one during a code reviewer you're going
to look into bugs and that's actually
very interesting because of course we
all have like testers that desks our
code but they actually test our
functionality and they almost testers
don't know how it's actually implemented
as a developer you have this interesting
insight where you know how it's built so
you also know possible weaknesses and
you can actually make use of that in
testing it through the interface or
whatever so that's also a very
interesting point of view
now I mentioned pool requests but
there's a few different types of code
reviews and these are two of them so on
the right you have the the progress
review which can be done remotely and
you can use pretty much any versioning
software has code reviews I think SVN
has girth written down so we can say
have and github has the PRS bitbucket
etc etc and on the left side you have a
pair programming which is also a very
interesting a little bit different type
of code review but it's still a coke
review and I'll go into both of these so
the progress review like I said
basically looks like this
you haven't progressed with which is a
title and it has a description where you
say okay so I built this and that and
perhaps you know this this is how you
can test it and you can assign people to
it and you have a little files change
tab there which you can see what the
actual code changes and this is the same
for most systems so that was github
it's still called get up right or did I
miss something okay I don't know they
move fast and yeah so you have bitbucket
and you have also good lab these are the
examples I gave you but then we also
have pair programming
who here has done pair programming
before okay why am I even standing here
who does it every day see that's
different okay cool
so pair programming you basic I didn't
need to tell you this but you have a
driver the person actually writes the
code and who's at the keyboard bashing
away and then you have the navigator is
someone who looks I guess at the bigger
picture and and thinks about the
solution you're building but also things
about hey you know we're building this
right now but maybe we should also
change this part of the system like it
affects each other right so you can have
a bit more of a zoomed out point of view
which is very interesting and the
interesting part about programming is
it's actually the shortest possible
feedback loop because with a pull
request you have to make the progress I
have to wait for someone to look at the
pool rest and then you'll get feedback
from someone
whereas with pair programming its
immediate right as you're writing it
you're both thinking about it and that
pretty much makes it too short as
possible feedback loop now there are
some other people who do this thing
called mob programming
I done my programming I haven't oh so I
haven't okay so I end up yeah okay
that's quite a few people actually who
does it every day
I'm so happy No
[Laughter]
yeah so MA program you have one driver
there and you have multiple navigators
which is very fun I don't know if you've
ever said band a computer with four
developers but it wasn't a good
experience for me so no but in all
seriousness it can be very useful to me
it's useful when you're building this
this new feature and it's it's quite you
know impactful on your application it
could it could mean a lot for your
architecture or it can be really complex
and at that point it might actually be a
good idea to just suit 15 minutes maybe
half an hour of my programming just look
at the problem together and just you
know write some code just just some
mock-up code some proof of concepts and
that way you can all get a sense of you
know what the problem is like or what
the solution could be so yes it is it is
useful but don't overdo it I guess
unless that of course it works for you
so a while ago I think it's two years
ago now I did a survey on Twitter mind
you there's a huge selection selection
bias in my survey because if I if I
tweet something then it's mostly the
people in the community which is your
that I reach and those are also the
people that are more likely to be
exposed to presentations and to have a
company culture where code reviews are
normal so not all the questions are very
representative of the entire field of IT
Adam unfortunately but it's still very
interesting what I saw so one of the
first things I asked is do you have
colleagues review your code who has
colleagues review their code wait why
are you here now there will be some tips
and tricks don't worry okay so I
couldn't exactly count but 73% said yes
17% said only when I add four who it's
only when I asked a few people here yeah
a few people okay yeah yeah that's fine
don't worry then we have we use pair
programming as a form of code review who
has that you don't really do code
reviews with just pair programming okay
like five or six people okay and then we
have no we're only reliant automated
tools or no eight tests are only
function test the code or just
No so here is the follow-up question do
you feel like you learn a lot from
giving and receiving countries who
thinks who feels they learn a lot from
giving or receiving countries every
almost everyone that's awesome ok cool
so I've given this presentations
presentation quite a few times and I get
different results in a smaller group you
can actually see the people who don't
put up their hand and it's sort of
similar there's usually one or two
people we're like not really we just
find out on judge is whatever you get
out of it right
but 96% says yes I do feel like I learn
a lot giving and receiving overviews and
then I asked do you enjoy getting your
code reviews who enjoys getting their
covered youth I swear they're less hands
now so 67 sorry 87 percent said yes and
13% said no sorry usually but sometimes
I find it hard to accept feedback or
deal with criticism and I'll be very
honest I was part of the 13 percent in
the beginning when I started working at
Anne Rice where we did code reviews
every day it was a bit I mean I'm not
this I'm not someone with a big ego but
it was still very difficult to to have
someone constantly give feedback on the
things that you build that's a normal
thing for people to have right so I was
having some difficulty over now and then
to really be constructive about it so I
looked into this a little bit more and I
came across this term egoless
programming who's heard of egoless
programming before I guess - okay
perfect
see this is where you learn things so
eaglets programming I'll read it out to
you a developers neither robust enough
ego to trust and defend their work but
not so much ego that they reject
suggestions for better solutions
similarly the egoless reviewers should
have compassion and sensitivity for
their colleagues if only because their
rules will be reversed one day now
there's a very interesting detail in
here is they're really talking about
egoless programming not the egoless
programmer right there's a big
difference as a programmer you need an
ego because you need
proud of what you build you to have
confidence in what you do and trust your
own work but the work itself should not
have an ego the work the work itself
should be you should be able to shoot at
it without hurting someone's feelings
right that's ideal I mean you can't
always do that but that's ideal so I
listen to this a little bit further and
I came across this the 10 commandments
of Eagle is programming so this is going
a little bit off topic of court reviews
but I think is very interesting still to
share it with you so the first one is
understand and accept that you will make
mistakes like I said in the beginning
the presentation is very important to
make mistakes because that's how you
move forward right that's where you
learn the most from so understand and
accept it you are not your code it's the
egoless it's Eagle is programming not
that you go this programmer there's a
big difference no matter how much karate
you know is someone else will always
know more in fact this is one of the
rules that I live by I read somewhere I
don't know where but somewhere it said
if you're the smartest person in the
room you're in the wrong room
because when you're the smartest person
in the room that means smartest on some
specific subjects it means that you have
to do you have to put a lot of effort to
keep improving yourself and keep
learning new things right you have to
really go out there and go to these
conferences whole scary and stuff and
you have to really get all this
information by yourself whereas if
you're working in a company where
there's a lot of people who are smarter
than you and you can learn a lot from
them it becomes a lot easier to do that
on a daily basis right don't rewrite
code whether consultation if you think
there's a certain piece of code which is
like oh it's it's ever a met functions
in every walk instead of a for loop and
we've all had that right who prefers
every functions over for loops a little
bit scary yeah so but the point is don't
just rewrite that because you think the
other solution is better always go
through the extra original developer or
someone else in your team and ask is
there a reason why why we did it that
way and at least talk about it and don't
just change otherwise you'll just change
it then the other person comes across
and changed it again and you get this
battle of commits and it's really
awkward
treat people who know less than you with
respect difference and patience I am NOT
explaining this one read the code of
conduct the only concert in the world
has changed your codes gonna change
requirements are going to change its
effect your code is not meant to last
you hope it does but is not meant to
last the business changes right the only
true Authority center of knowledge is
not for position this is a very
important one actually it doesn't really
matter if you're a lead developer or
senior CTO or junior none of that
matters what matters is what do you know
what do you know that is important to
others if you have put a year year or
three time into learning about mobile
development there is there should not be
a single other senior developer who
works on PHP be like oh I know this
better than you so I should I should be
the authority on this know the
authorities this person who actually
knows about this who has a knowledge
right titles don't matter they shouldn't
fight for what you believe but
gracefully accept defeat also speaks for
itself if you're in a discussion with
someone and you're like okay maybe that
other person has a point sorry the other
person has a point accept it and accept
your defeat move on and improve because
what matters is your your code what
matters is the team the projects and not
your own personal opinion right that's
not our kind of wrong and out of context
your personal opinion does matter but in
the end it has to be constructed right
don't be the guy in the room this refers
to the person who comes in grabs the
coffee suspend his desk puts the
headphones on and just doesn't talk to
anyone does his or her thing and goes
home at whatever time don't be that
person you have to somewhat socialize
with people as scary as it is I'm sorry
and critique code instead of the people
the kinds of code instead of code again
this is the ego bus inglis programming
not the eaglets programmer so what do
you look for during a review in no
particular order I see someone was
taking the photo did everyone it's for
you you were standing ah hi we can we
have time
wait plenty of time there you go oh I'll
just stand here as well like this yeah
don't forget the hashtag we camp 18 how
you don't I can't see if you're done
give me feedback come on
oh yeah sorry I'm done
so what to look for during a code review
everyone has it right so in no
particular order
unhappy paths you know as a developer
you're kind of happy when a feature
works right you're proud of it like hey
it works I see this button there I'm so
happy took me as close to say you see
this to get it working but always think
about an IP pass what would happen if
this server would have coffee port on so
you don't actually have to do it but
what happens if what happens if this
third party cloud service goes down or
something else crashes I mean you have
to think whether it's relevant for your
project I mean does your project really
need that resilience but if it does make
sure you look for it as well and also
you know think about the exceptions
sounds weird are the tests added for me
it's always important not to look at how
many tests you have but at the
percentage the code coverage basically
I'm not gonna go into the 100% and 100%
code coverage discussion but just make
sure that when you when you introduce a
new feature that the code coverage stays
at least the same right preferably goes
up a little but at least the same is the
feature implement according to specs
when you have for example progressed you
have the description where you say ok so
I built this always make sure to go back
to the original ticket to see if that
was actually according to what the word
owner whoever wrote it if it's actually
correct and if you're not sure then you
can always go to the product owner and
ask so this is actually what you wanted
and just make sure that it's according
to the specs and another important one
is a performance who err works for the
very performance
important application for us do you have
performance tests run it's quiet why is
this so quiet
do you yeah so how often do you run
those performance tests once a week okay
cool so there's not a lot of people that
do perform assess continuously like they
you know we check things like we build
something and then they're like alright
we're almost life let's just throw some
butts against it to see how it holds up
and then it holds up and then we just we
grow but we sort of forget to continue
the check for performance and if
performance is important for you then it
might be interesting to invest some time
into making sure there are tests running
you don't have to run those tests on
every pool request or anything but at
least you know like every week is that's
pretty good that's that's cool
also don't overdo it don't go into the
oh it's underscore null is better or
worse than oh yes single quotes - double
quotes yeah double quotes more it's
heavier performance because they use
interpolation and that's a check okay
I'll stop security also very important I
was actually forgot this one in the
first version of my talking someone
pointed this out to me and I'm very
happy that he did so as developers we're
kind of spoiled now and this is also
interesting to think about the
developers that come into our field
today our developers that grow up to use
a lot of abstraction layers and even
though abstraction layers are cool
they're really cool because no one
really wants to write that low-level
code constantly you do forget what
you're actually working with it you do
sometimes become lazy when it comes to
security and that's dangerous now it's
always good to know you know what does
this abstraction layer actually do and
it's it's good to know the the risks
behind it
SQL injection is not so much a thing
anymore because of abstraction layers
but it can still be a thing if you if
you use it wrong right so keep thinking
about security for example cross-site
scripting still happens a lot it doesn't
sound a serious but it could be very
serious if
it happened if it happens on a certain
place right
also there's tools out there I forgot
the name it's the composer secret
checker so what it's cold huh yeah
security advisories yeah I think are
those two separate tools or isn't it
same tool okay we'll just imagine
they're two separate tools so there's a
a tool that you can use in your your
your built in your your continues
integration which checks for the
packages that you have and it can check
are there any known security
vulnerabilities for these packages and
it can warn you about them it's a very
simple way an effective way to at least
be aware of what you're you know what
you're putting on production
okay so let's dive a little bit into
code review etiquettes I I think most of
you didn't know it existed it doesn't
exist I made it up but I do think it's
interesting because I think the way that
we communicate with each other is very
important when it comes to code reviews
sure you know we say like oh eclipse
programming an englis programmer but
that doesn't mean you can just like say
anything you want you still have to use
a certain subtleness right we're
developers we have hearts as well most
of us anyway um so curvy etiquette I
have a few examples these are all for
open source repositories and it might
look like nitpicking every now and then
but I'll it I'll show you
so this is from it looks like Magento
module you can tell I worked with
Magento not anymore by the way don't go
on to me with Magento assignments so
Brisson blue says I usually like to keep
one line between functions it looks like
you have two here and this will apply to
all my comments related to code
formatting Wow and then person Rhett
says that was simply mistake made when
adding my code might take from this is
don't jump to conclusions I mean it's
quite you could quite easily say hey it
looks like there's an empty line here I
wasn't intentional and you can sort of
assume that most of those things aren't
done the intentional and actually you
can get rid of most of these useless
comments by using tools like beach pcs
fixer or be a good sniffer or anything
else right
then another example is person read says
please use slash star start at for link
for the class properties and then person
blue says I'm sorry but I don't think
this is right convention for this by the
way this will not be managed by CS
figure tools if you use it's as far as I
know do you have a you link about that
I'm curious there comes to cook excuse
me
and then person read says it's fine and
then person blue says find what and then
person read it's fine to put it on one
line
so communicate clearly right this is an
open-source project most of the time
this this was within the same day so
that's it's okay like you didn't impact
much but this could have costed a lot a
few days before this feature could have
been merged so make sure that you don't
say it's fine but explain to the other
person another example this is from
laravel I believe where the person added
a file exists check and a person read
says you can't use the file exists
function you must go functions on the
files objects person blue response
thanks for the feedback but I didn't see
your main points honestly please correct
me if my understanding was wrong the
purpose of putting this check inside to
create cache directory is not to throw
exception yada-yada-yada
and then person to read replies not sure
you understand what I meant this class
can't know about the file system you
have to make that check through another
class that does and this is what I don't
really get why not use an example right
we work in a field that has a lot of
remote workers we work with people with
different backgrounds different
languages and the interesting part is
one language that we all speak in PHP
lands is HP so why not use PHP to
explain what you meant it's much easier
to do that then try to use English to
talk about programming right so I mean
github is great formatting for its index
highlights and so it's very easy to do
and of course most important thing is
say thank you every now and then when
someone build something thank you and of
course use gifts I said all right I got
it I was reading it next slide I was
like I'm gonna get this one yeah use
gifts this is what
my colleague left me in the on the
progress reviews and here's a few more
in case you didn't have it up I like the
kid on the top right he's fabulous he's
great are we done alright so moving on
another important thing is with coke
reviews you owned a code as a team you
can no longer say that person wrote it
right because you you both work on it if
you do the code review you're
responsible for the code as a team and I
still see this happen to way too often
brands like oh yeah that person missed
something no you miss it as well because
we did a code review right it's our
responsibility not that single person's
responsibility so team effort which also
means that in your communication you
leave in comments for people I'd like to
make sure that I say we should or I
think we should do it like this instead
of I think you should do it like this
right team responsibility and maybe even
more important is to ask what do you
think there are so many developers
definitely people that just start out
junior developers maybe interns that are
very very smart they're very smart I'm
scared I'm afraid of my job but the
problem is they're maybe not as
confident as other people because they
haven't had the same validation that
you've had so always make sure that you
ask you know what do you think trigger
them to say something about it and don't
accept them being like oh well you're
the lead developer you must be right
that's that's a wrong thought right what
do you think and you'll find that
there's a lot of cool answers that come
out of that it's the quiet ones for what
the most interesting
so it's interesting enough since
everyone here does cover views this
getting started as going to go it's
going to be quite simple so for progress
reviews you can start by introducing
branching right we you know the get
branching model everything create a
feature branch
put it over cast up against the
developer master branch and that way you
can easily have a point in time where
you can all look at the code before it
gets merged but also ultimate menial
tasks like code style checks and linting
and this is the example that I mentioned
earlier you don't want to have your code
review clutter too with things like oh
there's an empty line here oh you should
put a new line after this because that
just removes the point that doesn't
remove the point but it loses his focus
right as a developer you start to look
for the wrong things and and seeing all
these syntax things and and commenting
on that it's in habits you from actually
being able to look at the actual code
and look at the architecture and see
those things right also linting is built
into PHP so there's no excuse I'm not
using it
beech P - L although it's quite hard to
do it for a role directory but why
haven't we fixed this yet let everyone
participate let everyone be part of the
code reviews is that something only
elite you do everyone should do it why
because you're sharing knowledge you're
continuously sharing knowledge and you
want everyone's input everyone needs to
be included and with that also give
everyone the right to merge having one
or two people only do the merging is a
very large bottleneck and you don't want
that code reviews are not meant to stop
the process or introduce obviously it's
more time Court views you know you still
want to keep up the pace so I have
everyone I give everyone the right to
merge and make sure you still move
forward as a project because some things
are just not not important enough to
really follow I mean you can even do it
like do people do code reviews and then
we were just right you don't have to do
one code review in that version so how
do you improve car reviews what we do is
we also do a functional review so when
someone creates a progress their person
also tells us the test steps that you
have to go through and that way as a
developer will be doing the functional
testing as well because the earlier on
you spot a bug
the cheaper it is to fix right if you
spot a book somewhere when it's already
deployed or whatever then it taken us to
be moved back someone has to dive into
this task again and fix things and that
just takes more time right so the
earlier on the better so what we usually
do is we have two code reviews and one
functional review and which can be done
by two people two different people right
and as well I get a kind of therapy I
don't know why people say take a second
opinion but get a third opinion if you
have a discussion with another developer
it's sort of like team a versus team B
right it seems like a very inefficient
discussion to me so when that happens
and you notice this after three or four
comments on on the progress then what we
have within my team is we have the rule
that the third person has the deciding
vote right until the third person comes
for the third solution that is so that's
a party but generally there's always
like two two teams right and so we just
say okay so we have this discussion and
the third person just makes a choice and
we move on because unless it's a very
very important part it probably isn't
important enough to really spend so much
time on and everyone accepts this rule
which makes it a lot easier to function
as a team
definitely when you're a bigger team
keep changes small I think this des
speaks for itself if you have a very
large pool request it does a lot with
your cognitive load right does a lot
with because when you go through you
have to remember the state you have to
remember all this changed here this
changes here so that means we can call
this function here and the bigger it
gets the harder it gets to follow all
these things so you want to make sure
you keep them small and make it easy for
the for the reviewer and also for
yourself
really amen
don't trust the developer when a
developer says yeah I built this and you
can test it like this or I used this
this method instead of dismiss this
method because the other method didn't
work you don't necessary have to
question everything the developer does
but it's definitely good not to just
assume
that person is indeed or that it's
indeed not possible doing it the other
way always ask like why why did you do
this I'm interested to know and I would
like to see maybe it is possible if we
do it a different way but yet don't
trust the developer and something that I
see happened way too few is this review
using your favor - who does I'm not
gonna necessarily call you a little hot
on it but who reviews using just the
github in your browser files changed
right why I mean you're use phpstorm
every day most people here have an IDE
they have some sort of environments that
they're used to coding in right and it
comes with a lot of interesting things
it it gives you a possibility to click
through onto functions to see which
classes implement these interfaces and
that's what you're used to so why would
you limit yourself to the github
interface for example and you know
having to just look at just simple plain
text with some colors into it you can
actually pull in this code and you can
do a diff within phpstorm
and you can see what the changes are you
can still go and click through things
like you can even see if there's methods
which are unused and these are things
you don't spot on on get out you know in
Petri so it's nice and great you can
sell how this private methods not use
anymore because we reflected something
and those are very entertaining sites
you also get more of a sense of the code
structure the directory structure and
then shared vision shared vision vision
for me is very important because it
gives everyone a a basis to base their
their choices on their their decisions
right if you all have a shared vision
like we want to be here as a team or as
a project and every everything that you
come along that you come across along
the way you can make decisions based on
knowing where you want to go right and
this solves a lot of questions love
discussions that happen uncovered is
because discussions during court reviews
are very expensive you want to keep them
as small as possible because the longer
the discussions go on for the longer
the the business has to wait for that
feature which is a waste you know you
want to deploy quickly you want to move
on right so make sure you have a shared
division and one way of doing that is
what we call an architectural
exploration don't try to Google lists
there's literally nothing on there it's
just something that we made up which
helped us a lot and basically it comes
down to this while you're coding take
notes things you see things you want to
improve or things that that come up
during a code review take notes schedule
a meeting I don't have a recurring
meeting oh we're gonna do this every
week because you'll have meetings that
aren't really useful you know you want
to make sure that the meeting is
actually we have plenty of meetings
already time box it to whatever time you
want present a discuss so talk about the
things that you came across I think oh I
see this thing here we're still using
these components but it's becoming a bit
messy now and I would like to improve it
and you can even do a suggestion during
this meeting and make sure everyone's
involved invite everyone even the tester
right have everyone involved all
developers and talk about it and that
way everyone knows what the thought
process is behind a decision and when
people know the thought process behind a
decision it's a lot easier to accept
right sometimes when you come into a
project you're like oh why did we use
this and you don't sometimes realize
what happens that that led up to that
decision and it's important to to be
aware of that I also have a last
question in my survey which was why
aren't code reviews part of your
company's workflow and these are the
reasons that came up we have 38% who
says we have never discussed this which
is to me it's a shame sort of like you
should at least mention it you can you
can say no we're not the kind of company
to do code reviews that's fine but at
least discuss it or I talked about it
then we have 30% saying we feel our
projects are too small to do code
reviews this is completely
understandable I mean the company I
worked for at the time it might have
been too small to do cartridges if
not have been useful enough you know
having those landing pages the campaign
sites are online for like a month
yeah I mean sure you can you can still
do it but not necessarily I can only
send that then we have management think
it's a waste of time of money okay
we'll get back to that and we have as a
developer I don't see the value in doing
court reviews which is probably also the
same person who said I don't enjoy
receiving cookies or has the same four
percent so to finish this talk I have
one that slides on convincing your
company in four easy steps to stay in
the whole clickbait idea
disclaimer I've never had to apply these
steps I literally just came up with this
and thought hey this looks like a good
idea if you do go and try this let me
know if it works if it doesn't work I'll
scrap this slide from the talk I'll
never talk about it again it doesn't
work I wouldn't so start the trends ask
someone hey you know would you can you
review my codes right be vulnerable can
you refill my code
oh I'll return the favor I'll review
your code as well and then hey we can
learn from each other it's a lot cheaper
than sending people to trainings and
workshops constantly if you can just
learn from each other as well measure
the impacts you know how many bugs did
we find during his cart review like what
kind of improvements that we do sure
your boss hey look we did a lot in just
15 minutes time half an hour time
everyone's like half an hour that's fast
I take two hours no joking
so one of the reasons to be increased
customer satisfaction you know the
customer will experience less bugs less
issues when it goes into production and
developers are constantly learning from
each other it takes 15 minutes for
feature although I should probably
change this because it doesn't really
take 15 minutes for feature depends how
big your features are and make it part
of the price you know it's not something
that you as a company have to pay for
it's the quality that you want to
deliver to the customer don't be afraid
to have that price
[Applause]